how's the gum rest my name's better than
that a little you know what that means
what that's gonna happen out what is
this it was all a dream or was it so
that was our first day at South Park
that was one heck of a day man I saw all
the [ __ ] that we don't use what's for
the sound it's [ __ ] shout outfitter
quake alien probe is obviously more
appropriate okay we got any message from
Randy thanks for getting me out of me I
tried to tell him to stop but I'm just
too polite hello Hart Randy's like
secretly gay yes let's take a [ __ ] I
guess get that probe out of our right
system oh [ __ ] it's so hard to [ __ ] in
this game well maybe another day I think
something's gonna be wrong
no where's her parents so I get again
upgrade I am mistake Sam I didn't really
like the jujitsu so I'm gonna go with
circumcise and the other one so that's
cool mastery oh my god they came out of
nowhere there was a huge earthquake in
it and if there was burning in my yard
did you hear about it it's all over the
news here look and that a large
earthquake and several fires in the
South Park area last night won't many
residents from their sleep here with the
report is a [ __ ] in a bikini
Tom government workers here are assuring
everyone nothing out of the ordinary
ha ha ha ha ha they claim that the only
reason huge tents have gone up to cover
this area is to mask the construction of
a new Taco Bell which will open sometime
later this month oh my god I can't wait
did I do love me some Taco Bell the
mayor of South Park states that last
night's tremors and fires are under
control and that hopefully schools and
businesses can open again soon it's
horrible Eunice
the elves they took a stick and it's
[ __ ] because that is totally
cheating we specifically said no trying
to take the stick at night elves are
dirty little liars and we have to lay
waste to their entire base you have some
incredible ability to make friends
quickly sir douchebag I'm sending you on
a quest to go out into the lands of
Sauron and recruit a whole nother
faction tacuba cape find the goth kids
and give them this letter get them to
join our kingdom and we shall lay waste
to the drow elves once and for all
[ __ ] Cheers
so emo goth kids are a faction that's
great I should know where they are
they're outside the school or whatever
so I guess we have to dress up like oh
hey Kenny I miss you ah don't worry
about it Kenny now we're back in here we
are
there's the goth kids I've seen them
here I think they should be here unless
they move goth kids never move now
that's now Kenny don't be scared just
you're with me my god they're really
dark and they're real out so goth hey
what's up a little cat I think it's not
new kid people are talking about beat it
new kid this area is strictly for goth
kids
what's this join the kingdom of Koopa
keep to bottle the wicked elves all
recruits welcome sorry Frodo
we don't play dungeons and douchebags
yeah beat it new kid we never do
anything no way we can't do what this
kid asks us to do
he's a conformist look his clothes in
his hair yeah I'll tell you what new kid
get the right clothes and some
cigarettes and coffee and then talk to
us again yeah if you want to prove you
aren't to conformist then you need to
look exactly like we do then maybe we'll
consider hanging out with you what
what's the difference between emo and
goth i never understood that i actually
liked the city walk would bring back
their mongolian menu I actually like
gothic interior design
it's a shame gothic people just [ __ ]
ruin everything about that area cuz I
don't know it's it is nice
this is [ __ ] ruin it goddamnit um
alright so we have a quest we need to be
nonconformist of God so much che so do
you brothers like join certain trends in
how people dress and [ __ ] like that like
emos or maybe skated look or may give
you a good price
I'm never given I can say that honestly
I never given up to any fit in trend but
maybe cuz I don't really care about it I
think you realize what it's you're older
how stupid it is to do that just to kind
of like you wear certain clothes just to
be part of a group
I I guess I guess it will come to you
one day we look back and you'll be like
[ __ ] why did I wear that stupid [ __ ]
this actually looks pretty good honestly
maybe I never mind what I said you have
to meet where that you move out get down
it looks pretty swagalicious the dealer
is actually extremely appropriate what
else do we need
Edgar is trying to sleep on my keyboard
okay we need my cigarettes and coffee
well there's a coffee shop right here
sorry just suggesting my balls
speaking of balls Edgar gets neutered
tomorrow let's get it we [ __ ] it awesome
I'm so excited alright so copy my coffee
shop
thanks for helping tweak out in the back
room would you like to try some coffee
yes I would like some tweek Bruce
darkness spite - just in case
alright one more goddamn elf kids let's
fight them hey there yet you can't new
kid the elf king is requested your
presents you can either come quietly or
you can fight but I warn you fighting
this fight at this point in the game is
a complete waste of time and you might
as well skip it and just come with us I
want to fight them those wisely new kids
come with us no I said fight then I
click welcome to the mind of the great
buddha pi 100% mentally challenged
who's the elven King though oh it's
gonna be although they are awesome elven
so you're the new kid everyone is
talking about what's your name
he doesn't talk elf king he thinks he's
hot [ __ ] or something I am pretty hot
[ __ ] you're playing for the wrong side
dude what did wizard fat-ass tell you
did we broke the rules and took the
stick last night he's lying Cartman is
the one he should be fighting against
he's hiding the stick which is cheating
and acting all betrayed and sad to get
you to recruit more people for him we
tracked a twitter raven who say you are
currently trying to recruit the Goths
for the wizard go recruit them but bring
them to us common stupid Kingdom and get
this dick back once and for all I'm
trusting you to do what's right and kid
if you betray us we'll tell everyone
you're a button Oh No level seven holy
[ __ ] I'm gonna upgrade my my
circumcising I am sending our best
ranger to help guide the particles while
your disposal down oh cool but gets an
ax
Jozef raise banners around town claiming
elf territory for their own so sayeth
the well of insight plus it's all over
Twitter can be restored only if a chosen
one were to [ __ ] up their banners these
human banners are dark tidings will no
one break the [ __ ] out of them any ally
of the elf king is an ally of mine and
my shop is open to you so fab
hi it's ten awesome nice Pepsi bottle Oh
every causa house yeah we are
let's check out a house room it's always
fun to see all the references or
whatever oh yeah he's so ugly without
the hat man
Chewbacca hello what the hell okay so
hey man have you seen the new Taco Bell
yes incredible that's true [ __ ] I'm the
mighty frost giant I stand in all of you
here will okay whatever 18 friends holy
[ __ ] I'm fabbed 4 to 5 plus cool baby
alright where's the yeah there's one
here and remember okay we need to
[ __ ] Cyprus beer I thought I'd try it
out my cigarette tastes like you're okay
get lots going to smoke here take your
stupid hair and leave can I just fight
them what is Randi saying she's
messaging me man
shut up Hey if 20 people like this post
some side said I'll win a free iPad and
Randi Luxus take your stupid hair and
leave ah let's just fight them come on
let's do this alright let's see what we
can do hearing sling of David on those
[ __ ]
Wow
let's see what Sam can do mark for death
what is this whoa
go get a boy huh what's that stand sword
let's try that okay
pretty amazing alien press so disgusting
man
with circumcised that guy it's so brutal
like poor guy alright what do you get
Stan exceed is spinning oh okay
they're all kind of similar they attacks
or whatever dude we're pretty badass the
[ __ ] is that oh we got the lighter okay
okay this type of game I hope like lasts
for a long-ass [ __ ] time kiss assist
this is really fun to play it has a good
feeling to it and it's cool you never
know what's gonna happen either which I
guess it's something I appeal to hello
my sword is fired and [ __ ] hi can I be
our friend no its butthole the Barbarian
from the dungeons of dumbass it's search
bag looks better yeah he's almost Agha
being caught isn't just how you dress
it's a frame of mind it's time for you
to prove that you go against society's
rules yeah there's a big PTA meeting
happening right now at the community
center you need to walk right into the
middle of that meeting and take this
sign to their table yeah that will prove
your individuality go on beat it and
don't come back until you have a picture
of that sign tape to the pta table well
that sounds pretty easy yeah fun in
there I think I'll wait it out whatever
okay [ __ ] the conformist it isn't right
I tell you out of nowhere this huge Taco
Bell is being built and our children are
missing precious school time
that's pretty sweet of me assured by the
builders that they are working to fix
whatever problems they've encountered
and schools should be able to resume
soon resume soon who do they think they
are they think we're gonna see a taco
bell's being more important than our
kids education what if it's not really a
Taco Bell we're dealing
thanks for coming new kid everyone this
is the kid whose family just moved to
town we've become very close friends
his name is what's your name sir
douchebag well anyway this child and I
witnessed something last night and I'd
like you to hear his story go ahead kid
tell them you know about all that
go ahead Tom telling us stuff how he is
a waste of everyone's time
if the PTA isn't gonna do something
about Taco Bell taking over then the
rest of us parents will so that [ __ ] the
conformist anyone I'm the conformist why
are they a good lay mm-hmm
why don't you exercise your free speech
at home little boy
no don't we screwing around in here the
[ __ ] is he doing anyway it's kind of
habit saw you on the ship you have
pretty good control over your [ __ ]
thank you ma'am this is a PTA meeting
young man be on your way I used to have
a bad hoarding problem okay but I got
past it now can just throw things away
would you mind throwing this away for me
I just need to throw it away somewhere
very specific I'll show you on your map
montage montage what am i doing
can someone tell me what in that not
Nats okay we're gonna poop we're gonna
do right ah [ __ ]
oh well maybe another day hello hello oh
it's your Pokemon hello
no I didn't want to put my wanted to pot
okay what [ __ ] i pooed like I never
put food before and poor okay well
that's good I don't blame you for now I
have a guy finally look I know how
you're feeling okay but this isn't gonna
solve anything
we've got to get inside that Taco Bell
and find out what's really going on help
me with that and I'll help you with this
I saw you on the ship you have pretty
good control over your farts meet me in
the bathroom it's time for you to learn
some real power to pound I thought I had
control of my [ __ ] not not not my
fart Tommy to see two different things I
can tell you have potential but you are
undisciplined let me show you what I
mean I have a prophet come at me trying
fart on me come on he's part of the
broke lat what key gah you call that
farting on someone you missed by a mile
try again okay I'm sorry
distracted by your bra right hi ha that
your farts over there somewhere
didn't come close so what do you do when
people can block your FAR's must learn
to control your farts to move and
release at a specific time and place I'm
going to teach you a fart called
the sneaky squeaker it will become your
greatest ally don't believe me try and
block my attack this sneaky squeaker huh
oh damn huh how do I block it how do I
block it whoa is it gonna go inside my
walls huh you see that I distracted you
distracting your opponents is key to
battle look let me show you again pay
special attention to the viscosity okay
you tried make your fart detonate behind
me okay
Liga's okay mr. Macky are we gonna time
it you sneaky squeaker to distract mr
Mackey over the corner there what's
gonna happen I'm not sure if this is
such a good idea
Randy all right look here we go hey you
guys hear that sounded like a chipmunk
it smelled like one tear Jago ha ha ha
very very good
now use what I taught you to sneak
inside that Taco Bell find out what
they're up to and report back here and
no matter what happens never fart on
anyone's balls you got that right now go
I want his armor it's [ __ ] awesome
the bro ninja clan is renowned in many
centuries but be aiming to control their
fudge all right how many car crashes
have you been in sad five and a half
scuse you all right oh [ __ ] that sure
looks like a Taco Bell alright folks
there's nothing to be concerned with
here absolutely nothing out of the
ordinary is going on simply getting
ready for the grand opening of a new
Taco Bell new Taco Bell opening soon
very big Taco Bell it's gonna open in a
few weeks thank you I'm so [ __ ]
excited go bail be serving in churritos
what is it gonna be a full menu Taco
Bell or is this gonna be one of those
Taco Bell KFC combos we got a guy out
here asking a lot of hahaha just stick
to the script is laid out in the
protocol but he wants to know if the
Taco Bell will have in torito's or not
sir damn it we don't have a contingency
for that Michaels isolate neutralized
the threat yes sir
it's a simple question but there's gonna
be a huge Taco Bell will it serve in
Cerritos I think we have a right to know
thank you Mark folks we know you're all
very excited but for your safety we ask
you stay clear of the construction site
it's horrible while they did ask a lot
of [ __ ] question that's what you get
yeah he's that alright sorry about that
can I loot him yeah might as well I
wonder what something USB dry we're
gonna have to check that later
sorry absolutely nobody allowed past
check back in a few weeks thank you
can't wait for that time way to get past
people well I can fart on that oh yeah
the sneaky part okay
it did say right in there I think I
heard a beetle tiny elephant poachers
elephant poachers excellent skuzzle-butt
what was that all right now we go idiots
what is this oh we can Electrify him I
think someone's testing Tupperware and
that's how it's done
let's loot him who the [ __ ] cares around
a random screwdriver how nice is [ __ ]
up that's it's wrong man no all right
we're gonna have to find another way to
attack about we can shoot this not
exactly sure what you're asking
shut up why did I do that
that was completely oh wait we have a
anal teleporter thank you
all right well guess we go up in hmmm
what awesome
there we go baby
[ __ ] yeah it's going here I [ __ ] so far
we've been unable to stop the UFO from
leaking the toxic waste we've contained
all we can but there are no guarantees
an outbreak will not occur and does the
alien liquid appear to have the same
effect as last time I'm afraid so when
the alien waste reacts with organic
material on earth it turned things into
nazi zombies so that's what it is here
we go again god damn it I'm so tired of
nazi zombies it's so overused if the
wrong person gets their hands on that
green toxin it could totally spread it
we have a big problem all right we're
going to have to completely obliterate
everything in a three-block radius find
locations for the bombs and bury it all
then make up a fake story about an
earthquake we can contain the outbreak
this time if we act quickly enough let's
move everything we've just talked about
has been recorded onto this tape I'm
going to leave it alone here for a few
minutes then come back later and have it
encrypted and locked away so nobody ever
hears what was said in this meeting yes
good idea that is a good idea actually
I press hope you enjoy watching if you
did please leave a like it really helps
me out a lot and helps keep the series a
lot as much as possible and be
normalizing go Adam
right now I'll see in the next one
tomorrow thousand I love you